so our goal is to make a seemingly
impossible domino run that you have
never
ever seen before
plant you want to get our social
distance measurements back up
you know you're defeating the point if
you're actually touching people with
these things
so nvidia sent us these new laptops that
have really nice workstation gpu using
them they're the uh the quadro
rtx and these gpus not only are they
great for 3d rendering and video editing
and all that kind of stuff but you can
also do physics simulations on them
so what better way to take advantage of
a workstation gpu than to do a physics
simulation with thousands and thousands
of objects
let's team up you guys are cg wiz kids i
ain't so bad myself and let's make an
impossible domino's run
[Music]
let's make a video real quick dude let's
just make a video real quick
dude i'm sorry you're touching the end
of it right now
i actually love dominoes man i mean when
i went to comic-con like 10 years ago
dude we built a domino run that turned
on the lights
it's controlled destruction i think
that's what's so satisfying about it
it's this very intricate cool looking
design
one false move and the whole thing just
is wrecked i feel like there's so much
hype with these things
it's like the same crowd who goes to
watch a building demolition
is probably watching these videos too
the thing i like about domino's is when
you can actually
scale up the size of them because a
domino can knock over another domino
that's one and a half times bigger
you can scale that up but the problem is
that if you're doing that for real
you end up hitting this barrier called
reality where you can't make anything
bigger than that
do you think it's like cheating to do it
in cg instead of doing it for real
no no you embrace the cg like a computer
simulation of a domino effect
is just as satisfying if not more
satisfying because you have to consider
the fact that you can do the impossible
in cg
but you're still using real life
dynamics to control
and set up the impossible so it's still
real physics like you still have to make
the physics work
yes so our goal is to make a seemingly
impossible domino run that also looks
real
you will see a domino run that you have
never ever seen before
i think we can do it in three shots each
one growing in complexity and maybe even
a scale of the dominoes as well we start
with the first one like in the studio or
something doing like some crazy cool
little pattern going along the ground
then it goes and hits a diamond
formation that makes the corridor logo
in the middle of the floor here and then
continues onto the wall it's about to go
out the door
and it goes up the wall maybe it goes
around the corridor logo
how do you change the direction of
gravity you're not a windrunner how do
you get it to go up the wall
you would have to do it in two separate
simulations and you'll just take that
entire
second domino scene and rotate it 90
degrees
and just put it up against and then just
line it up it's technically three
separate sims because you have one up to
the wall
two going here three restarting normally
and
dropping here and then it disappears
around the corner and then we just cut
to outside
we have a little line goes zoop out to
here and it goes ding ding ding ding and
then i get to like
click size dominoes right it'll just be
a snake down the road
and then what happens i mean red has
this drone
so then we can scale them up to the
point that they're bigger than any
dominoes can physically exist in real
life
really leveraging the use of cgi here
right it'll be so cool
man oh hold up we're going to be filming
an invisible domino run
yes and we don't know how fast they're
going to move so i think what we need to
do
is we need to set up like a two scale 20
foot long domino run
on the computer and see how fast that
moves dang to be so sick if we could
just like
do this right now on the spot but oh
wait this is actually perfect
[Music]
can we just take a moment to appreciate
that clint is using his
thigh as a mouse pad dude it's the best
mouse pad honestly 20 feet
yeah let's do 220 feet all right i'm
gonna hop into the shade here
hey milo milo hello
hey milo
all right nico let's let's focus on the
important things um
so i'm gonna take a second here and talk
about the hardware we are using so this
is the razer blade studio
it has an nvidia rtx quadro in it so
that's a really fancy version of a
graphics card and what makes this
different well it has more vram
vram's useful for like when you have to
have textures on the card for your 3d
scenes like when we render stuff in
octane or in the case of uh if you're
doing like machine learning you need to
hold like bigger models on it or for
example if you're working with like 8k
red footage another thing that's really
important to having a good workflow is
having good drivers so nvidia has their
studio drivers out now which accelerate
things like adobe premiere and after
effects or cinema 4d for example so that
it fully utilizes their gpus
to run fast and smooth so in this case
we're going to be doing a bunch of
physics simulations with a bunch of
rigid body objects
all these kind of things really benefit
from good gpu integration and that's
what nvidia has with their nvidia studio
drivers
good are you done yet yeah actually this
is actually going at a rate of
immigrant song this domino line is going
five feet per second
if you walk to the tempo of immigrant
song by led zeppelin you will be walking
at five feet per second
you know that's about the space you want
to walk that speed is only for that size
of domino
if you were to increase the size of that
domino that speed is actually going to
increase pretty substantially
so we know the speed of the regular size
dominoes let's go ahead and make a two
foot tall version of that same domino
and just like literally run the
simulation to see how fast that is
come to the land of the ice and globes
snowing time it's
time to go dang that moves quick hey
ren we have our answer can you ride at
13 feet per second
13 feet per second how many miles per
hour is 13 feet per second
oh yeah that's nine miles an hour that's
slow
i easily hit 20 miles an hour right
there all right so rent can go the right
speed we
have to plan for our shots now we just
have to execute right now ren's going to
go out and get the drone shot while
clint and i start working on building
our domino sequences
and you might wonder why we're on the
laptops in the studio well outside of
the fact that the uh
the gpus are fast for physics
simulations see
ren's computer isn't here we took our
computers home so actually it's a really
good thing that we have these
laptops to work on in the studio because
our computers are all gone anyways
so i'm basically piecing together three
simulations because you have one up to
the wall
two going here three restarting normally
and dropping here
and then once we have the footage i'll
be able to tweak the spline path and all
this and that
it'll look real nice nico is actually
going to build a really cool corridor
logo
made from dominoes um shouldn't take too
long i'll just be using black and white
dominoes
i'll just set it up and i'll test it out
knock them down and i'll move on from
there
i'm digging i keep messing up my shot
look at all these trucks
messing up my dominoes all right you
ready
they're getting bigger they're getting
bigger
oh no it's gonna hit the highway boom
all right
[Music]
nice all right guys i got the shot so
this would be the corridor logo
right here five foot diameter how long
is it is the logo gonna take to fall
down
i need to have that in my mind as i'm
actually recording all of it so nico
there we go
freaking two and a half seconds three
seconds to be exact that's really cool
man this computer handles like a
thousand objects like it's nothing
at some point i'll get to where i kind
of like come up and i'm looking down at
the quarter logo and i just kind of hold
it the dominoes get to that point before
i get there
you just add some more snake turns and
if i get to the logo before the dominoes
have gotten there you just remove a
couple snake lines
exactly ready
that takes us to shot two which is out
on the street which one will shoot on
the one wheel
sweet we got it all right
okay uh we're good i think we got it i
think this will work so clint
yeah here you go oh wow i actually
caught it
i'm actually really excited about how
this is going to turn out so excited
about how this is going to turn out like
this is
the freaking stuff i'm excited for you
if you're watching this video you're not
subscribed to corridor
crew for you to subscribe to corridor
crew please subscribe
all right see ya see you man
[Music]
these cats are just roaming dude look at
these things
[Music]
so we have to make these dominoes look
super realistic and there's a few things
that i want to go over with you guys
on how i'm going to achieve that ren did
a great job tracking the footage
so it's seamless on that end right so
the first thing i want to do is
reference dominoes and get the look of a
domino you want to make sure your
dimensions are correct and then from
there we're going to use an hdri
which is basically just a bunch of
images bracketed at different exposures
combined together to give us the most
realistic lighting sphere here so if i
just navigate around our scene here you
can see that we're kind of going around
this hdri
image that ren took of the studio and
that's what's actually going to help us
fuse these dominoes with the actual
live-action footage
now when we're in the exterior scenes
what i'm doing is basically adding
sunlight here in octane you can see how
this gets like a real nice
realistic middle of the day type look
here
catch the swing there the next thing we
need to do to those dominoes is add a
number of
surface imperfections that's going to be
one of the things that is really going
to push this domino
above and beyond in terms of realism
because it's not a perfect domino right
out the factory gates
so this is a fingerprint surface
imperfection by cornelius domrick
and that makes things shiny and also
makes things rough and it just mixes it
all up so it looks like someone actually
touched these dominoes with their grubby
old fingers
and that goes a long way when these
things are getting knocked over one by
one and they're catching the glare
of the light from above it's really
gonna look nice when it's not
just a perfect factory glare so that's
just a few ways to really step
up the render here the graphics card and
these laptops
really make it easy to render quickly
all right so clint just called me he is
ready to show us the final shot so let's
take a look
clint i hope that hair clip kept your
hair out of your face by doing these
intense physics simulations
unfortunately this is the only time i
had my hair clip up so i couldn't see
anything the whole time so hopefully
these shots are good
yeah i've been working on this stuff for
the past three days i don't know i'm a
little nervous
i know those vfx eagle eyes are just
ready um to strike so
tear me apart dude my eagle eyes can see
an alias pixel from a thousand feet away
all right i am ready for this here we go
the forest oh looks good that that
little bit of shine
yeah it's all about the shine
a little bit of steps you got
you've got some quarter logo yeah looks
nice all right up the wall
oh you get just a little bit ahead of it
i remember we talked about that but
other than that looks pretty good
boom it looks really good it looks real
real like it looks realistic
the lighting and everything looks great
i think ren's hdri
that he took of the studio that's huge
in making something realistic is that
hdri i think it's catching the glare
really nicely
right here looks like you're just kind
of like flying over the ocean catching
those highlights
you know and it was tough just because
like i had to basically sync
up the speed of these dominoes to the
timing of the video
yeah it was actually pretty difficult
physics man it's chaos it's nature
i want to see the next shot yeah dude i
want to i want to see the outside shot
wait it just starts already halfway
through yep oh
already letting me go down i wanted to
see the transition from the tiny to big
it's too fast wow
the dominoes are out pacing around on
the one wheel red is magically flying
over the dominoes
yeah yeah wow the rendering looks great
though
yeah realism is like spot on yeah it's
all about that glare and i think you can
actually see
the surface imperfections here when they
catch the sun and the fall off to just
like the normal
kind of look that is definitely one of
the things
that makes this thing look as real as it
does here's the thing though here's the
thing
there's a glaring error there's a
glaring mistake in this shot i feel like
the sun direction doesn't quite match to
that truck shadow
absolutely not look at the shadows on
the dominoes right it's like basically
top down
lighting i was looking at the dumpster
and i was like ah that's pretty top lit
you know and why i didn't see this
freaking
shadow of the telephone pole yeah so 45
degree angle for the sun
so i actually tracked these shots in
after effects using the ae camera
tracker which isn't the best camera
tracker but it's the easiest to use
really this is an attraction after
effects it's impressive oh yeah no it
tracks super easy
nico you know you were giving me the old
gripe about
not having dominoes go from small to big
well dude well
do i have a shot for you oh man here we
go oh the last shot
there's a downhill transition i wanted
to see the first thing gets a little
crooked
i like that oh no we're out man oh man
whoa wow love you that you can actually
see the bounce light from the other
[Music]
dominoes
dude i didn't know you're gonna do this
yeah i ended up just going with a
freaking
giant domino explosion at the end it
works what a way to end it really well
some of these dominoes have minds of
their own and they start taking
flight flying around like little bats
you know they're agitated now
cool well nice work man i looked great i
think we've learned a lot
about how we should actually go about
timing up
footage and and the dominoes what we
have here is really cool
and it's really promising for doing a
crazy corridor video where you push us
even further and put some more time into
it
well dudes i look forward to doing some
more domino setups on these laptops so
yeah
all right well that turned out great
clint did an awesome job
and being able to do these kind of shots
on a laptop was super cool
it actually it unlocks a lot of creative
potential for us to be out like on the
street with one of these guys doing
physics simulations and ray tracing
rendering being able to edit out in the
field in the middle of a shoot with
8k red footage on the spot to see how it
looks so having mobile power
is awesome if you end up picking up one
of these nvidia studio laptops you
actually get three months free of adobe
creative suite
so go check it out link is in the
description below all right everybody
thanks for watching
and don't forget to check out the
corridor channel where eventually we'll
be posting another domino video that's
youtube.com
corridor alright see you later
so snoop dogg has asked me to bring
tupac back to life
for music video through new visual
effects
newly shot scenes 200 to you a
reimagined version of charlie and the
chocolate factory
i'm gonna put a nerf blaster on a drone
i wanna hit your drone out of the air
challenge accepted
[Music]
you